-Your partner in crime
on this show, Nick Offerman,
obviously your co-star
in "Parks and Rec."
You've known him
for a long time, though.
-Yeah, we met in Chicago.
We met at a really weird
house party.
And Nick was in a production of
"Clockwork Orange."
And he had a dyed red beard
and his hair was shaped into
devil horns.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
And you saw that and thought
that was interesting?
-I was like, "My man."
[ Laughter ]
But that was during a time when
if you remember in Chicago,
there was some factions.
-Yeah.
-Because there were
the improvisers and the sketch
and -- like, you know,
stand-up's kind of
in the same group.
And then the Goodman Theatre,
Steppenwolf,
like, professional actors.
-Yeah. Actor actors. Yeah.
-And then the alternative
theater Chicago actors,
of which I think Nick was one.
So everybody -- they didn't run
in the same circles.
-Did you have any -- did you
feel any crossover comfort
with those other circles?
-I felt like I could do
everything they could do
and they couldn't do
what I could do.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that bad to say out loud?
-No, no, that's good.
-Okay. But no.
They were amazing and I never --
you know, I never --
I never went
to Steppenwolf or --
Did you go to any --
-I think I went to
like three Steppenwolf shows
the entire time I was there.
-Yeah, I --
-I will say they were --
it was expensive.
-It was expensive.
-Yeah.
-But it was like Laurie Metcalf
and Gary Sinise,
all these amazing actors
that were there.
But we were...
-We were just, like,
scraping it by.
-We were just throwing hot dog
buns into the audience.
[ Laughter ]
In some basement theater.
-Obviously Nick is sort of
famously good
at building things.
-Yeah.
-And he's a craftsman.
You are not.
-No.
-Does he take advantage of --
on the show,
of the fact that you know
very little about crafting?
-Yeah. He could say pretty much
anything and he would just --
I would just nod.
-Yeah.
-As if I know what it --
[ Laughter ]
Like, there is a couple times
in it that,
it was kind of like a little bit
of a living stress dream,
where people would say,
"Well, all you need to do
is just plane this
and then it'll be
in good shape."
And I would nod as if I knew
what everybody is talking about.
And I would be afraid
people would ask me to do it.
But, no,
I can't make anything yet.
-The show is called "Making It."
You guys have a catch phrase
that is very inventive.
-Yeah.
-What is the catch phrase on the
television show "Making It"?
-Make it!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
-Did you shop around for others?
-We did.
-Or did you immediately --
-We went to -- We went to
a bunch of clubs.
We tried out a bunch of
catch phrases.
-Oh, like stand-up clubs?
-Yeah.
-You did, like, open mikes?
-We did open mike stuff.
We went on the road.
[ Laughter ]
We worked really hard.
And what was great is we
realized simple is better.
-Yeah.
-Always.
-Did you have any failed ones?
-We didn't.
-Oh, really?
We just tried one
and then we stuck with it.
[ Laughter ]
And then we also --
We could never quite say it
at the same time.
-Oh, that was the issue.
Just syncing up and saying it
together.
-Do you guys have a slogan here
on your show?
-We do have a slogan.
It's also "make it."
[ Laughter ]
-"Late Night with Seth Meyers"
and make it.
-Make it!
-Yeah.
That's weird.
-Make it!
-Oh, it's said differently.
-Yeah. Make it!
[ Laughter ]
We try to say it in a way that
they don't know
if we're going to make something
or they're supposed to.
-I like that. I like that.
It's really hard to think of
a catch phrase, you know?
Like, to -- and we didn't want
to do something like,
"Get out of here, loser."
You know?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, it's a very --
Well, it's interesting
because you guys are the hosts
of the show.
You're not judges on the show.
-No.
I don't have to do any of
that tough stuff.
-Do you wish you --
I mean, like --
I will say you are someone
who has opinions about things.
-I -- Yes.
-Yeah.
-I don't -- I would never want
to -- A creative person who,
like, is very vulnerable
and puts himself out there,
I would never want to be the one
that says, like, you know,
"Hasta la vista, baby."
[ Laughter ]
You know, I would not want
to do that.
-I think you could say, like,
"Make it to the door."
[ Laughter ]
"Because you outta here."
-"Make it your business
to get in the car."
[ Laughter ]
"And get out of here."
-"Make a door and then leave
through it."
[ Laughter ]
-But, yeah. You're right.
I'm very judgmental
and I do like to judge.
-But I can see that you wouldn't
take pleasure from, like,
judging an artisanal --
-No, I enjoy doing it with you,
like, just the two of us now.
-Yeah.
-No one is watching or anything.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-But I like that.
But if it was on a, like,
you Know, a TV show --
-Oh, yeah, no.
[ Laughter ]
Heaven forbid. That's the thing.
That's why I have a TV show, I
try not to be judgmental at all.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you now?
-You were on --
We had dinner last night
with some of our friends.
-We did.
-And you then had to -- you
were, like, kind of
the first one out the door
because you had to do
the "Today" show.
-I did the "Today" show
this morning, which was so fun.
And that show is amazing.
Like, it's a crazy circus.
-Yes.
-As you know.
But I texted a friend of ours,
because this morning
it was like an "SNL" sketch
that we had probably
written a million times
because I was a little hungover.
-Uh-huh.
-Not a lot of sleep, and I had
to get up really early.
And I had to do crafts,
which I don't do.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-With Al Roker and Hoda.
And I followed a story about
a giraffe getting pregnant.
[ Laughter ]
But it made me think about,
we used to joke all the time
that there would always be
sketches where we would think
it was really funny if it was
like the local newscasters
in Tucson
who were really hung over
and just trying to get
through the morning.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-They're like, "Good morning,
T-- Good morning, Tucson."
[ Laughter ]
Just trying not to throw up
the whole time.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I think we may have
even talked about it here.
There was like a -- I remember
there was a famous night
where we were out
very late at "SNL."
And then you, Finesse Mitchell
and Kenan Thompson had to leave.
Like, you had -- Well, you left
a bar, like, an hour before
you got picked up to all go play
the Black Eyed Peas in a sketch.
-Oh, that was such
a dark, dark day.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And you filmed it
and it was really exciting
for the rest of us because you
then all told us, like,
"We were so hung over
and we had to dance
like the Black Eyed Peas.
And then when we all just got
wait to watch the pre-tape."
And then it was so much fun
to watch because you guys
all looked like really unhappy
Black Eyed Peas.
[ Laughter ]
-And Kenan Thompson was doing
the funniest bit
where he was pretending to take
calls from himself
the night before.
And he was like, "Hello?"
And he was like,
"You want me to go home?
I don't think so."
[ Laughter ]
He was, like, going,
"You got to go home, man.
You're going to be up all night.
And you got to be the
Black Eyed Peas in the morning."
He's like, "Nice try, buddy."
-How about, by the way,
our friend --
Our friend Kenan Thompson
finally got an Emmy nomination.
-So great!
Give it up for Kenan Thompson,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And still an American citizen,
Kenan. Right?
-Yes, still -- no, no.
They took it away for Horatio.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-So now he's --
-They had to split --
they switched it.
-Oh, makes sense.
That makes sense. Yeah.
-And that's how it works.
-That's how -- that's the biz.
-We don't add one more person!
-You know what,
you want to be here?
You got to give us someone!
[ Laughter ]
A friend, preferably.
-A friend. Ideally a friend.
I love you so much. Thank you
so much for being here.
-My pleasure always, friend.
Just a delight
every single time.